je m'appelle fabia manille je suis
chargé d'opérations en aménagement sur
les espaces naturels
ce métier je les choisis parce que déjà
mangé ma formation et l'information
c'est à dire c'est pas dans
l'environnement proprement dit mais
c'est un métier qui peut servir dans
l'environnement
ces informations au bâtiment génie civil
je m'occupe tout ce qu'il dit
l'aménagement sur nos sites à savoir
tout ce qui dit les points d'accueil les
kios les bancs la signalétique
travaillant en étroite collaboration
avec ce qu'on appelle les gestionnaires
de sites c'est à dire c'est la plupart
du temps ce sont des associations qui
gèrent le site et que nous on travaille
en collaboration par rapport aux
différents aménagements surtout pour
l'accueil du public ont fait tout ce qui
dit même des réhabilitations de maison
on va peut-être voir sur ce site il ya
une vieille maison créole qu'on doit
réhabiliter pour les besoins du
gestionnaire pour les besoins du site
et puis le confort aussi des ouvriers
qui se trouvent sur ce site
cet aménagement au milieu naturel c'est
vrai que c'est un peu différent des
aménagements qu'on a en zone urbaine
parce qu'on a beaucoup quand même
beaucoup de contraintes pour nous avons
des sites qui se trouve encore des pas
donc lorsqu'on fait un aménagement on
peut pas faire un aménagement comme ça
on demande toujours l'autorisation
nous trouvons sur le domaine archambault
ce domaine appartenait à l'ancien maire
de saint pierre
monsieur augustin archambault qui a été
acheté par le département en 1997 le but
de l'acquisition de ce domaine c'était
la préservation de la forêt se méprend
une primaire qui se trouve à l'arrière
du domaine
et puis à l'avant nous avons une maison
du 19e siècle
si le créole et là on a lancé des études
pour la déconstruction et la
reconstruction à l'identique d'un
consultant un maître d'oeuvre c'est un
architecte qui a fait ces aménagements
et ses plans avec notre validation avec
un programme que nous on avait on a fait
le programme propres et à l'art
nous avons aussi sur souvent des sites
des espèces protégées
donc tout ce qui dit construction doit
se faire avec la biodiversité avec le
site
et puis son histoire et puis les espèces
qui existe sur ce site
il faut avoir quand même la fibre
environnementale puisque c'est on est
dans la direction de l'environnement
donc la préservation de tel ou tel site
est de ne pas construire n'importe
comment donc les conditions cessé
d'aimer la nature est d'arriver à
construire des se former aussi de
construire avec la réglementation en
vigueur pour pas trop dénaturer on va
dire la nature
et puis on apprend des choses aussi on
apprend à construire avec la nature on
apprend à préserver on apprend plein de
choses différentes que des constructions
en zones urbaines
mais ce n'est pas mon métier romandie
aménageurs puisque le public quand il
quand ils viennent ici c'est pour voir
le site d'accord pour voir aussi pour
voir la biodiversité
on parle que de la nature d'accord moi
je suis aménageurs j'aménage le site
pour que les personnes c'est-à-dire les
personnes qui visitent se sentent bien
et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui de 10
par rapport à ça par rapport aux visites
par rapport aux touristes par rapport
aux personnes qui veulent découvrir la
nature le métier d'aménageur est
primordial